what is it like for you on set trying to
make your day how bound are you by the
hour the minute
number one I'm the executive producer of
this movie and I'm also the director and
I think it's super critical that
boundaries are set right away and in the
case of well Newman with my producer he
personally was responsible for you know
in advance in pre-production scheduling
my day along with the DP and Matt
Edwards who was the DP of the movie is
really the most important person on the
set because if he slows down or can't
make the day that he previously agreed
to you know this has a incredibly dark
story at the end of the day because the
next day you've got a whole nother list
of things and what made will such an
asset to our movie you know and then
again also am at an incredible asset is
your ability to be honest with yourself
you know and I mentioned earlier that
the screenwriter had a beautiful third
act where the
hot-air balloons were being chased by a
truck and the the actors were hanging
out of the truck and hanging out of the
balloon and I mean there's just no way
we could have done that in even in an
economical way in less than a day versus
the way we ended up doing it is in less
than a half a day on the Rio Grande
that was our creative solution that the
screenwriter agreed to and you know if
she didn't agree to it we would have
come up with something else
but the outcome of it is we collaborated
on it and as a producer and a director
it was my goal to make the day every day
and I think we made the day every day
but one day and the reason we didn't
make it that day was something something
that was unexpected happen and it
happens all the time in the business I
mean one of the the real tragedies of
doing independent filmmaking is is is
you know
things that you can't control so my
movie takes place predominantly in Taos
New Mexico and in LA and I made a
significantly smart decision to build a
kitchen here on my stage that we could
flick a switch each day and modify the
lighting but never have to worry about
the Sun going behind the building next
door never have to worry about going
into overtime and and this no alight at
all it gave us an ability to do probably
two times more work on the stage than we
would have done in New Mexico at a real
restaurant and most importantly
creatively I was able to you know work
with the set designer and create
something that I feel was one of the
most magical parts in the movie is her
domain her restaurant her her dining
room and all that was made on my stage
you